[Music]
click the activate Google cloud shell
button at the top right of the console
window a cloud shell session opens
inside a new frame at the bottom of the
console and displays a command line
prompt it may take a few seconds to
initialize once your cloud shell session
is ready to use you can do things like
go to your home directory and use VI to
view your bash RC configuration in this
QuickStart
will preview and deploy an app engine
application first clone the sample app
and run it locally in the cloud shell
session using the App Engine development
server click the web preview button and
then select the port number from the
displayed menu cloud shell opens the
preview URL at its proxy service in a
new browser window when you are done
previewing the App Engine app type
control C to stop the development server
now that we've previewed our app we can
deploy our App Engine app using g-cloud
app deploy this may take a few minutes
to complete once deployed you can open
your application in the web browser the
URL is at your project ID appspot.com
now if the application has not yet
finished deploying you will see an error
message in the web browser simply wait
until deployment is finished and refresh
the page congratulations you've
successfully previewed and deployed in
App Engine app using just your browser
thanks to the power of cloud shell
you